foreign
welcome to another installment of Harry
Potter Theory today we're discussing 10
things you may have missed from the
Deathly Hallows book I've already done a
video on this for the film version so if
you haven't seen that then go and have a
look afterwards the Deathly Hallows is
perhaps the darkest entry in the entire
Harry Potter series filled with war and
death the book follows the final moments
of Harry Potter's quest to destroy the
horcruxes that Voldemort hid around
Britain with so much lore and so many
intertwining stories it's easy to
overlook some of these smaller
interesting facts and tidbits that fill
its pages so today we're going to take a
deep dive into the final chapter of
Harry Potter's life at Hogwarts and
ReDiscover some of the things you might
have missed 10. the book dedication it's
not uncommon for authors to dedicate
their book to someone but most of the
time these educations are glazed over by
the majority of book readers this is
because these dedications aren't
significant to us they're also usually
possession towards the very beginning or
very end of a book near the beginning
they're an obstacle and near the end
they're an afterthought and for those of
you who don't tend to linger on the
table of contents Pages or dedication
Pages you may have missed JK Rowling's
final book dedication which she happened
to position into the shape of a
lightning bolt this is of course a
reference to Harry Scar and one final
symbolic thank you to Harry 9. the only
book without a quidditch match for most
of Harry Potter's life he didn't have
much to be proud of under the care of
the dursleys he was constantly mocked
and belittled the few achievements he
managed to earn were often dismissed or
downplayed so realizing his full
potential as a stunning Wizarding
athlete was one of the most empowering
aspects of Harry's life his early
victories as a quidditch seeker and the
hard work he channeled into his practice
was one way that Harry recovered from
his abusive life in the Muggle world and
with the war against Voldemort in the
Deathly Hallows at the peak it's easy to
forget that there was once more to life
than fighting against dark Wizards so
you might have actually not realized
that the game of quidditch one of the
most important aspects of Harry Potter's
life was never even played in The
Deathly Hallows 8. Snape Harry and
Voldemort's deaths the ancient history
of the Deathly Hallows is deliberately a
mystery lost to the ages although the
myth of the pever brothers seems to be
mostly true there are many Among The
Wizarding World who dismiss it as Pure
Fantasy and fairy tales but when we take
a second look at the story of the
ill-fated siblings we'll find that their
deaths were eerily similar to the ones
that Severus Snape Tom Riddle and Harry
Potter shared in the final book when it
comes to the peverle brothers each of
the three boys died in a unique way
befitting the type of gift they
originally received from death the one
obsessed with power died when a thief
tried to steal his Elder Wand the
brother who sought the means to
resurrect the ones he loved died because
he couldn't get over the death of his
true love and the final pavril the one
who simply asked for an invisibility
cloak so that he could hide from Death
had the most peaceful death of all if we
compare the perval's deaths with Snape
Potter and Voldemort we can see that
Voldemort died in his quest for power
Harry Potter died in peace just like the
pevel brother who first possessed the
cloak and Severus Snape's death as
heroic as it might have been was all due
to the love he still bore for Lily
Potter he loved her so much that he
would risk his life for her son
7. Harry jinxes himself at one point in
the Deathly Hallows Harry Potter and Ron
Weasley ended up discussing Ginny the
conversation might not have seemed like
anything special at the time but by the
end of the Deathly Hallows a comment
that Potter made ingest actually came
true in their conversation Harry quickly
remarked that his relationship with
Ginny wasn't that serious and he wasn't
going to marry her or anything crazy
like that but as we all know Potter
actually did go on to marry Ginny
perhaps that moment he jinxed himself or
more likely JK Rowling smartly knew that
this bit of back and forth between Harry
and Ron could be used to foreshadow The
Chosen one's future 6. potty mouths as
Lord Voldemort's power grew The
Wizarding World seemed to grow
progressively dimmer darker and more
complex the brighter times of Harry's
early years at Hogwarts were
increasingly foggier and foggier by the
time of the Deathly Hallows Harry and
the world around him had matured to the
point where death was a real consequence
that children faced and war against dark
Wizards was a tragic but true reality so
the language of Harry's friends and
mentors naturally changed as well adults
and students were no longer forced to
stick to polite etiquids and often when
the circumstances weighed the Order of
the Phoenix down you could hear many of
them use abrasive curse words when
talking about the opposition
5. what Snape a Secret Keeper Albus
Dumbledore was the secret keeper for the
order of the Phoenix's secret
headquarters and when Severus Snape
murdered him in the battle for the
astronomy Tower the knowledge of the
Phoenix's location passed down to those
that survived him this naturally must
have meant that Snape himself acquired
the knowledge as well which makes us
Wonder did Snape ever reveal that
address to Voldemort before Harry heals
himself Harry Potter was no slouch when
it came to Magic he was an impressive
duelist defeating far more experienced
dark Wizards in open combat and even
without the aid of Severus Snape's old
school book Harry would become quite an
expert with potions but for all of
Harry's abilities he struggled with
healing spells he famously relied on his
friends and the caretakers of Hogwarts
to deal with his most Grievous injuries
but during the events of the Deathly
Hallows Harry displayed a unique skill
using magic to close her cards perhaps
with the war growing ever more dangerous
Harry brushed up on his healing magic or
perhaps this is just a tiny
inconsistency
3. the seven Potters was kind of useless
if you've read the Deathly Hallows then
you'll remember how Harry Potter was
successfully escorted from the home of
the dursleys in order to avoid his
demise at the hands of the Death Eaters
the Order of the Phoenix decided to
disguise themselves as Harry and hope
the Death Eaters on their Trail chose
the wrong one but if you took a moment
to think about it this plan doesn't
really make sense since the Death Eaters
had the ability to track the order's
magic Harry's friends were hesitant
about using magic openly but in the end
when the Death Eaters attacked they were
forced to defend themselves with their
ones casting colorful spells throughout
the neighborhood since they ended up
using magic anyway wouldn't it have been
better to Simply prepare a portkey on
the street outside and quickly Rush
Harry through to the other titles while
preparing the Deathly Hallows JK Rowling
worked tirelessly to keep the title of
the book a secret she swore up and down
the name of the book would be a dead
giveaway to the plot and she didn't want
to let fans know until the last possible
moment but even by that point the title
never seemed to be settled apparently
Rowling had a few other ideas that she
bandied around before ending up on the
Deathly Hallows these other ones
included Harry Potter and the Elder Wand
Harry Potter and the Hallows of Hogwarts
and Harry Potter and the peveral quest
I'm sure any of these other titles would
have been just as great but I'm glad we
ended up with the one we got 1. the
historical significance of the Hallows
now when you first heard the title the
term Hallows might have had a strange
ring to it while only a few modern words
originate from Hallows the phrase
Deathly Hallows has a strong historical
root Hellas were often times holy relics
that were connected to Saints or other
famous church leaders and even before
the rise of Catholicism Hallows were
associated with powerful Pig Heroes who
had Divine Heritage while calling the
Elder Wand the resurrection Stone and
the cloak of invisibility Deathly
Hallows JK Rowling was drawing upon a
millennia old tradition which seems to
indicate that they had Primacy in the
magic world as the most powerful items
to ever exist and there you have it 10
things you might have missed when first
reading Harry Potter and the Deathly
Hallows as always these books are
chocked full of Law and symbology so
there is much much more that you can
find and when you do make sure you share
it with the rest of us in the comments
below if you enjoy the content please
like the video and subscribe to help
support the channel until next time
remember there is plenty to be learned
even from a bad teacher what not to do
how not to be